welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse in Mysterio's illusions against
Peter Parker just could get more and
more elaborate and manipulative
according to spider-man far from home
director Jon Watts
who just revealed Mysterio used
subliminal messages that we didn't even
realize were there to fool Peter and
perhaps to fool us I'm gonna break down
these visual Easter eggs and other ones
throughout the film that you might have
missed in this special update episode of
inside
okay John Watts said that in far from
home the most important scene to the
story was the moment in the prog bar the
heart tart between Quintin Beck and
Peter Parker after they defeated the
fire elemental monster she's actually
just a big fake hologram you know how it
worked
Peter handing off Tony Stark's Edith
glasses leaving and then the bars
projections fade in a way to lead to
Beck's revelatory victory speech is this
sequence the entire film hinges on it
needs to come as a surprise which is
tough because most comic fans went into
this movie knowing Mysterio was likely
gonna be a but also to make
sense of the information we've gotten up
to this point and to crystallize the
exact nature of the primary threat of
the movie to keep us engaged for the
next hour so what said that the way he
made this work was by studying con
movies and the real world art of
deception in hypnosis applying it to the
scene by billing this bar with
subliminal messages so these Easter eggs
are two-tiered they have to work on
Peter to trick him into giving over the
glasses but they also have to trick us
the audience so that we also momentarily
trust Mysterio so the coming twist hits
as a surprise so let us review this
scene beat by beep to find all the
details a snuck in there hey you
gotta celebrate did some good tonight
okay so there are some new things that
come up here first we learn in a few
minutes that most of this bar is being
hala projected by Beck's holographic
technology via drones and some of the
people in it are Holograms but the
others are members of team Mysterio what
I love about it is that the opening
frame of the scene reveals everything we
need to know about this operation at the
bar on the Left that's Janice the
bartender of course this goo Turman and
framed under the beer tap that is the
most recognizable the team William get
to Riva so if you happen to be looking
at the right corner of the screen and if
you remembered that Peter Billingsley
played that stark engineer that Obadiah
Stane screen box for scraps app you'd be
like whoa wait there is eight total
conspiracy going on here also Goodman
showed up earlier stalking behind Peter
and MJ in Venice along with Quinton back
in that background so if you have a
photographic memory of faces you would
also be like whoa wait this movie's
reusing extras or yeah there's a total
conspiracy going on here also the music
that mysterious team is playing in this
bar this is town called malice by the
jam the
lyrics describe the feeling of missed
opportunity being stuck in a bad place
instead of living the life that you want
so they're playing this song to put
Peter in headspace of an angsty kid who
just wants to make some decisions for
himself for a change and Beck uses
carefully chosen words and repetition to
make Peter verbalize this once what do
you want Peter what do you mean what do
you want I don't know what do you want
you Peter Parker now I know you're
thinking about it I want to go on my
trip and go to the top of the Eiffel
Tower with the girl who I really like
and tell her how I feel and give her a
kiss
ah so just like some kind of
motivational speaker that coaches Peter
repeating what do you want to get him
out of his head to stop thinking about
his Avenger responsibilities and instead
think selfishly he also learned some
valuable Intel about MJ in eiffeltower
that he will use later in that illusion
sequence but also John Watson splain
Deeja Klee placed on the wall behind
back are images
designed to put these thoughts in Peters
mind notice there is a framed row of
military medals that are positioned on
the wall over his shoulder to remind
Peter of Beck's past as a hero soldier I
was part of the last battalion life
trying to stop them all so right beneath
those military medals is a photograph of
what is that oh yeah a pair of glasses
so T Mysterio is using subliminal
messages to implant a simple math
equation in Peters head let go of your
Avenger responsibilities plus trust this
war hero plus glasses equals give back
the damn glasses all Peter needs at this
point is his finger on that trigger
which is the next step of this con are
those needed glasses yeah he's on the
floor ah notice the look that Beck gives
that apparent Czech stranger who's
actually part of his team he's dead
serious because this sleight of hand was
the most critical move of this entire
con this woman pickpocketed Peter
dropped the glasses to her other hand
and then handed them to Peter and all
happened so fast because if she took too
long or if she just tried to steal the
glasses and run at this point Peter
would have noticed they were missing and
he has to make the choice to hand them
off to Beth and after this Beck quickly
chastises Peter for leaving them on the
floor and Peter what's damage
just a little jab at Peter for being too
irresponsible to carry this burden
himself and now finally that the glasses
are the subject of the conversation Nick
can move on to the most powerful
influence on a teenager body shame try
them on let's see how they look on you
can I be completely honest with you
please you look really stupid mysterious
so salty but hey hook line & sinker
Peter cannot wait one more second to get
these things off his face and complete
the subliminal math equation that
Mysterio had implanted in his mind hand
them over to the war hero who has earned
them are you thinking twenties time that
you see that cause Peter kid here
reinforcing the stark like paternal role
he has been playing for Peter from the
moment they met wearing Starks glasses
and Iron Man esque armor back in Peters
eyes in this moment is the perfect
successor of Starks legacy all Beck has
to do is act like he doesn't want that
legacy you know a bit of reverse
psychology and bam
mission accomplished oh yeah superheroes
are so easy to manipulate all I gotta do
is neg them a little and they'll give
you the literal nuclear codes
so is Mysterio the saltiest supervillain
I don't know if anyone can out salt Loki
or I don't even know who you are knows
but comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at a vas it subscribed to new
rock stars who join us as we go deeper
in deeper inside Marvel thank you for
joining me and don't feel too bad body
shame is exactly how Philip got the
Edith glasses back for me
[Music]